So just one day after we got our hands on
these extraordinarily incriminating
suggesting that Donald Trump's lawyers henchman
I'm talking of course of Rudy Giuliani's henchman,
Lev Parness and Igor Fruman.
Uh, after the texts exposed that they had
ambassador Maria Bonovitch under physical
surveillance, Nancy Pelosi and the house of
representatives have moved forward with the
impeachment of Donald Trump sending the two
articles of impeachment over to the United
States Senate.
The vote to do this was almost among party
lines or along party lines, I guess I would
say two 28 to one 93.
The only Democrat Colin Peterson, uh, to vote
a no was a guy who is known as a Democrat
in name only.
Collin Peterson.
Frequently grandstanding with Republicans
despite being a Democrat in some technical
sense.
Uh, the house also voted to approve seven
impeachment managers.
Now these, these are all Democrats of course,
who are effectively going to act as sort of
prosecuting attorneys against Donald Trump
in the Senate trial.
This will be explosive.
It's going to be ugly.
We're going to talk about the proceedings
and what we can expect a little bit later.
The seven impeachment managers that have been
selected are Adam Schiff, Hakeem Jeffries,
Jason Crow, Jerry Nadler, Sylvia Garcia, Val
Demings, and Zoe Lofgren.
Maybe the most interesting inclusion in that
list is Jason Crow from Colorado.
He's a first term Congressman.
He's not on the house judiciary or intelligence
committees from which every other impeachment
manager hails.
But the theme here is that everybody who is
going to be all seven of these individuals
have, uh, either law degrees or law enforcement
backgrounds.
Interestingly, Zoe Lofgren has served in all
modern impeachment related proceedings.
She was a staffer during the Nixon pre impeachment,
which never became an impeachment.
It ended up with his resignation, Nixon's
resignation.
Once it became clear that impeachment would
likely lead to a conviction because Republican
voters and Republican senators had abandoned
him.
Uh, she was on the judiciary committees, Zoe
Lofgren during bill Clinton's impeachment,
and here she is again, uh, during Donald Trump's
impeachment.
The trial is tentatively scheduled to start
Tuesday, but there is going to be a lot of
lead up before what you and I would consider
the trial actually gets going.
I'll talk that a little bit later.
We're still trying to figure out what will
be public, what might they push behind closed
doors.
When we know more, we'll know more about what
we will or won't be.
Live streaming.
My instinct is to stream as much of what is
public as possible and we'll talk about that
a little bit later on in the show as well.
There are still questions about what witnesses
are going to be there.
Remember that while you need two thirds of
the Senate to convict Trump, uh, 67 senators
effectively, which would be 45 Democrats,
the two independents that caucus with Democrats
plus 20 Republicans, in order to convict Donald
Trump for subpoenaing witnesses, for agreeing
to subpoena witnesses, you only need 51 you
only need a simple majority and that means
you only need four Republicans.
Assuming all 47 Democrats and independents
are onboard, only four Republicans need to
agree to subpoena a witness.
Someone in order to make that happen.
We've heard that Mitt Romney wants to hear
from John Bolton.
So is does that mean he would vote to subpoena
him?
That's one vote that you would still need
three more.
And then of course the normal names are always
floated.
Maybe Lisa Murkowski, although maybe not,
maybe Susan Collins, although often not.
Um, maybe Cory gardener, although we can't
really say the same sort of general questions
apply to which documents are going to be allowed.
Certainly the absolutely insane text messages
about Maria Bonovitch being under physical
surveillance, watching her movements and relaying
them back to left Parness that should be part
of the trial Senate majority leader, Mitch
McConnell is absolutely going to try to keep
those documents out.
And of course, Donald Trump's immediate reaction
was to start tweeting wacky stuff, which we're
going to look at in a moment.
I think this is a good time to remember.
We want to be evidence-based and when we look
at the evidence, we shouldn't irrationally
and, uh, irrationally optimistically believe
that this is a process that's going to lead
to Donald Trump's conviction.
I know that I still get emails from people
saying, David, don't assume as a foregone
conclusion that Donald Trump will be acquitted
in the Senate.
Okay.
With 99% certainty.
I, I've been reading a great book called thinking
in bets, which says we should, we should talk
more about confidence with 99% certainty Donald
Trump is not going to be convicted in this
trial, so therefore I'm going to try to focus
my analysis of the trial on the basis that
given that a conviction is so unlikely, what
is the best setup for ultimately helping to
push Trump out of the oval office by voting
in November of 2020 ultimately removing him
in January of 2021 given that it is unlikely
that a conviction is at the tail end of this,
what can Democrats do during the trial?
How can they manage the obstructive desires
of Mitch McConnell and other Republicans in
the lead up to the trial to most damaged Donald
Trump?
That's the lens I think is the most pragmatic
one.
If there are still people in my audience who
truly believe that the outcome of this trial,
that is it, we now know it's not at some vague
point in the future.
It starts Tuesday.
Unless something changes.
If I still have people in my audience who
believe there could be a conviction coming
at the tail end of this, I want to hear from
you.
I mean, I w I want to hear which 20 Republicans
do you believe might vote to convict or if
you believe that it's not about finding 20
Republicans, but it's about something in general
will happen in the next couple of weeks that
will turn the entire Republican party against
Donald Trump.
I'm talking about his supporters, uh, because
that's what it would take to get Republicans
to abandon him.
Get in touch and explain to me exactly how
you see that happening.
What will be the catalyst.
And in the meantime, again, Trump and his
family tweeting wacky stuff, which is what
we're going to look at next.